Donald Trump is getting sued you might
remember the name summers er voz she's
one of the dozen plus women who accused
Donald Trump of sexual assault she is
suing Trump for defamation she is the
former apprentice contestant who
previously alleged that Donald Trump
sexually assaulted her once she accused
Trump publicly Trump counteracted by
staging basically a national attack on
her calling her a liar she agreed to
take a polygraph test about her
accusations she took it she passed it to
the extent that polygraphs are reliable
at least we have that on the record and
she said she's willing to dismiss her
lawsuit if Trump retracts his false
statements about her and admits that she
was correct in her allegations of sexual
assault I am not too hopeful that Donald
Trump is going to say hey you know what
summer was right i sexually assaulted
her there's been reportedly no
communication with Trump's attorneys
there's been no discussion of a
settlement but Trump spokeswoman hope
Hicks said that this is quote more of
the same from Gloria Allred of course
this is totally fallacious pointing out
who the lawyer is that's representing
summers er voz doesn't in any way speak
to the truth or false and falsehood of
the allegations from the complaint this
is just one piece of it and some of
these allegations might sort of ring a
bell with you quote as soon as she
arrived at his office mr. Trump
immediately kissed MS servos on the lips
she was taken aback but thought perhaps
that mr. Trump just greeted people that
way they sat down and began talking she
was about to leave mr. Trump suddenly
kissed moszer bows on the lips a second
time it only goes on and gets worse from
there will this even get to the
discovery phase or is is it all just
going to be thrown by the wayside you
may know that presidents aren't subject
to criminal prosecution while they are
president but presidents are subject to
civil litigation and what's so ironic
about why Pat is back when Republicans
were desperate to get Bill Clinton about
the entire Monica Lewinsky situation
Republicans pushed for a change to the
law which allows sitting presidents to
be
bully sued as a result of that now
Donald Trump will be able to be civilly
sued hard to imagine they anticipated
that yeah and you can be civilly sued as
long as the infractions took place
before you took office yes so you got to
love how the Republicans set that
precedent I'm just glad that this story
keeps on going because it seemed like
shortly after the election the sexual
assault allegations just kind of went
away yeah if there's any credibility to
them they should still be in the
forefront Gloria Allred could
potentially if this goes to discovery
seek all documents and recordings
related to the allegations this would
include those apprentice outtakes
remember when apprentice producer Mark
Burnett we talked about this said
there's more stuff than just the Billy
Bush tapes we said wonder what that is
and then basically forgot about it
this could if it ends up going to
discovery surface some of those videos I
am highly skeptical that it's gonna get
to that point and apparently what Bart
Burnett has over Donald Trump could be
far worse than the Billy Bush tapes and
could make those seem like nothing yeah
I was thinking Donald Trump says no one
respects women more than me
when the new tapes come out if they
exist we might say wow he actually
seemed comparatively respectful in the
grab him by the [ __ ] tape if this ends
up hurting Donald Trump there will be
Republicans to thank for it remember
Republicans went nuts when President
Obama wore a tan suit to what they
considered to be a serious event they
don't even want to look into a dozen
sexual assault allegations the audacity
of Tony that's right yeah that's hope
taupe is like 10 right I think so I
don't even really know what taupe is I
don't think I own any taupe colored
clothing items Warby Parker is offering
a free five day home Tryon to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses I personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I liked the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like $300 for prescription
glasses high which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing